it's not an easy thing writing a book
but I like it I love the fact that we're
able to bring back all these great
memories and it was almost like a
bonding moment with our family and
friends again drew has better writing
than I do barely barely their memoir it
takes two hours story covers the twins
childhood in BC and Alberta - they're
crazy rise to reality TV stardom but the
brothers also dropped some bombshells in
the book Jonathan unfortunately I went
through a divorce and he was scammed
when his younger had to go through
bankruptcy
I was drowning in debt at one point from
financial hardships to Jonathan's
aspiration to be a famous magician the
magic of Jonathan Silver's interface
yeah I still perform every now and then
they even revealed their celebrity
crushes for Drew it's Saved by the Bell
cutie Tiffani Thiessen sure everybody
had a crush on her because she was
America's Sweetheart and Jonathan while
his bedroom was plastered with posters
are one of the biggest supermodels in
the world I am friends with Tyra the day
you know I met her and we you know
became friends like wow this is the girl
who is like my dream babe last December
drew proposed to his dream babe longtime
girlfriend Linda so between this book
tour shooting there many HGTV shows and
Dancing with the Stars how's that
wedding prep going true yeah yeah I'm
doing lots of wedding prep right now
Linda and I are renovating our first
home together that's a lot of work
through this and away the deadline to
complete the construction project before
setting the deadline for the wedding put
me in the doghouse yeah